買いました
[音楽]
はいというわけで今日は肇社長でござい
ます
私
はじめしゃちょー28歳にして初の
マイホームマイホームというか職場なん
ですけど新
始めシャツをハウスう
購入いたしましたあ
[音楽]
ちまって前も言っていたんですけどもお家
を買いましたもう
見てわかると思うんですけどいたりに
尽くせりでございます
やばいいいですよほんとにやばいしまさか
家にたを下ったなと思ってなかったて傘
多くじゃないんですよお供とサンオクで
売ってたんですけどもう握り構想といい
ますかなんかいろいろあって
ねえ切ったなぁ簡単には値切ったらターン
オフで売ってたんですけど僕が彼はなくて
ちょっと下がってあのまあ
に置く安全万ぐらいで最終着地したんです
けど弟カープの王子なんですけど音階を
買わせていただきました人体じゃないん
ですよオーナーが濃くなっても何でもして
いいという祖父になっております
します来県に来たりとか猫の周りウロウロ
したりってか前からちょっと欲しいんだな
と知らんですけど問題住んでた方が
いらっしゃって tree 社長に住んで
ほしいと思っていただけで購入することに
なりましたいやマジかっこいいよ見た目
から堂々
決死の決まるんですよもう状態ですねえと
いうか要塞にほぼんだってもこのカメラの
画角だと映んないぐらいの大きなんです
けどもこの動画でこの建物の全てを見せ
切ることても無理なぐらいいろんなことが
あるんですよねーずこの動画では3億円
だったり餌を買いましたというお話ね
ちょっとなんかは多いまた別の動画とかで
紹介そうと思うんですけどとりあえず外
願い筆記とか周りを見てほしいんで今日は
この私の舞フォームサンク ny フォーム
の周りを一緒に見ていきたいとおもいます
[拍手]
結構有名な食べ物っぽくてコソコソしてる
となる102年が嫌な広間に方するんで
堂々と外とっています範囲へというより
イメージ的には会社皆さん会社の住所って
公開しますよねそんな感じでも会社だと
思ってもらっている会社だと思ってるんで
弾み社長の会社ということで外観とかも
ガッツリ移していくんでほんとあのこない
でね迷惑行為とかこの隙に住んでる人とか
もどこが一発で分かると思いますけども
もういたずら行為とか悪質な盗撮とかあり
のズーミンの迷惑になるようなことをする
ようであればを会社として通報の社会的に
制裁を下しますのでそこでもよろしくお
願いします山見ていきましょう決め手は
ねぇ決め手はこのやすい時なんですよもう
最高だ
バターン室前はちょっとまた多い用意紹介
したいと思いますもが変換だけど京都が
お腹いっぱいだと思うのででこれ突き抜け
で奥には
庭が広がっておりますもう1回言いますよ
3羽が広がっておりますあの皆さんわかる
と思うんですけどもユーチューバーでには
を持っていることので母さんやばいと思う
んですよコレコレですよコレ頃にから
すべてねフェのもう圧巻バス今日何でも
できるんじゃないかっていう風な広いせ
もう
壁もできてるしで裏から見ても言えこんな
お医者なんですよ
ねここにガレージがあります空まあ結構
入る寄せでここもとまだ前に住んでる方の
ものが何個かあるんですけどもう夏に俺は
ああっには物になった母としても監視
カメラもめっちゃゾールされております
結構たくさんチャンスからついてますはい
ん
どこが出てるかわかんないでしょ俺も俺も
とかある言ってるかわかんないんですけど
もちょっと階段とか合っちゃったりして
登っちゃったりすると嫌ガーデンみたいな
空間がかかってるねって光景 ok じゃ
ないこれリヤカージェン何よもう
でまだ上がありますとん
あどうだエンゾ椅子取るかはクズてって
言われ
迷路なったらパパマジックおいても遅い
けどこっちもプールも版北京は何でも
できるあピアスとキャラや by ぬん家
にヤシの木ある奴見たことなこんな子近
距離で癒しの cad 座らしくパーク
しかないよいいなぁ多分瞬く俺の動画多分
ウクレレで流れていると思うのでそして
こちらでございます
[拍手]
いっかーもういいかもういっこじわがあり
ますが土工程俺 s よねてが館バールで
も3つあり方ようにまあ
か眼鏡で見られないんで外撮影はこことか
になるかなという教師ますってこんな駅
南部の写真でしょう本来は沖縄かグアムか
ハワイ
見ていきましょうか
来期になると思うんですけどちょっとまあ
黙ってくださいねまだ毛質に紹介されます
この動画で2時間半と目立っちゃって
いやーこのねーすごいよこれもいい色俺の
や漆芸人にいい
rats 待ってね僕が凄いとかいいが来
てこいなチャンスがあるなってなんかねえ
ええとか思うんってことでショットまた
オッティれてません前で亀頭ではあるん
ですけども非常心でもう全部僕の家という
ことになっております
[音楽]
はいというわけで夢のマイホームをついに
買ってしまいましたいろいろな設備含める
とほぼやっぱり3億ぐらいしてるぽいん
ですよやっぱ家買うのすごい大変で進退に
奴に払って住む家ってどうもお金払って
その身一つ入って書く買うとかでできるん
ですけど枚フォーム入りを買うっていうか
だとやっぱり連記とかとあの監視カメラお
めちつけてるんで警備だとかガスどうする
か電気とかボロボロ含めてかなりすること
がいっぱいあって買ったものですねまだ
すぐにすぐわけではないって徐々にシッコ
していこうかなっていう感じに当たってる
んですけども
かかってここに住むことになりましたやっ
すごいよもぅ
ビルモンコレもうなんかこうね利用可打っ
てさあ一つの人生の中の大きなイベントだ
と思うんで本当に大切に使いたいなと思い
つつもこういう実のところ全部使えます
からね
あの
スター園9したいですね15でちょっと
また外観しか紹介できてないんですけども
なんかすごい
てくるまだまだ見所いっぱいなんですけど
もまた今度の動画で紹介したいと思います
茶
[音楽]
ん
ていて
ブーフ
[音楽]
んブースん
me
[音楽]